now when you said these people that are
trying to save the world yeah like what
what do you what do you really mean by
that I think they're the people are
trying to build the kingdom of God on
the planet Earth you know to draw a
metaphor religious metaphor there are
people who see an evil and they want to
purge the world of that evil by any
means necessary and the evil being
privilege privilege and it white
supremacist a new religion say tree are
Christianity goes down that's just you
know the game of Thrones the only reason
you need new gods are because people
don't believe in the old gods right and
so we have these religious modules we're
having in our brain and the new religion
is intersectionality and we see that
really is what it is that's exactly what
it is the parallels we've been writing
about that and talking about that for
years and studies a little psychology
for years and it's it's all over it is
it is political correctness is
paralleled with blasphemy it's the same
parallels of heresy the parallels that's
exactly right yeah I mean it's it's so
stunning how easily people sort of slide
into these precondition slots here's the
one difference and I think this is a key
difference the reason that it's easier
and I mentioned this to Penn Jillette
when we did a talk and he just couldn't
believe it the reason that it's easier
to talk to Christian for example about
faith or about their religion is because
at the end of the day it comes down to
faith these people don't have any faith
they have knowledge quote unquote they
have their bodies of scholarly
literature which were idea laundered
that's what they have so they can point
to these things and say well I don't
know but if I know I know how do you
know well Robyn D'Angelo's white
fragility you know there's a study yeah
there's a study there's a study there's
a study I know how some of those studies
are written and I don't trust them and
you shouldn't trust them either yeah
yeah yeah well you see that I mean even
in nutrition I mean you see it in
everything this this I in terms of like
almost a religious or religion like
except exactly of specific ways of
eating or specific ways of communicating
specific ways of being it's just so
strange how people seem to have this
natural inclination to
adopt predetermined patterns of behavior
right yeah I think actually there's
pretty decent understanding of that from
from the perspective of moral psychology
you've got this idea that somebody has
has seen something as good so it
elevates them it makes them better so
clean eating might be good right
whatever clean eating means for some
people it's vegan for some people it's
like all you eat is grass-fed beef who
knows but you've got clean eating and
you've got dirty eating and you go into
the clean thing and so you've got this
kind of like purity thing and eventually
you take this so seriously it becomes
kind of a sacred value to you well
what's sacred mean you know we have this
kind of vague sense oh you know holy
this that that's sacred and it's
something really important to somebody
well what it really means is that it's
taken on so much moral importance to
somebody that they no longer will allow
it to be questioned with something
sacred it's now been removed from the
the sphere of being doubted questioned
or whatever and so when you have this
idea like that let's say that that
privilege is the cause of racism and
you've elevated that there the problem
with everything in society even then
you've elevated that to like a sacred
value that can't be questioned you can't
say maybe there's another dimension to
it that's when you start getting these
kind of religious like behaviors you're
circuiting these problems because you've
got a place where it can't be a question
be made